AL AT THE WHITE HOUSE, ANCNN. IL
INN'IM
SCIUTTO GEXS
TH POSSIBILITY ONG
ATTACKED BY THIA.
YI, THE FIGHTER JETS OR
ND GERMA
FORCE JETS, THTHEFSIAN AIRCRAFN
ATTACK, F AIR
ND WHAT SAIL
COMMANDERS S
INCREASINGLY
ON FLYING
SAILINGADYING FOR ANY AND
L COAT T
EXERCISES PLACEE BALTIC STRIKING
FLYING MIG 29 SUKHOI4HA
JUST LIKE T F FBURGRN
VERY HIGH READINESS TASK
DESNA TASK
OMMANDINER SAYS
THSERIOUSLY
TRAINI EXERCISING R
UIRED, WE CANLYO YTIONS
DETERR T
ALLIANCE WHENEVER IT IS REQUIRED
. IN THE VER SHORT MOMTASK FORCG
RUSSIATERRITORY. KALINGR
AND WE' P
OR EVEN HARASSMENT C TO CLOS
BY RUSSIAN AIR AND
AWARENESSFORCES IS HI R IN
THE MIDDL THE SIMEDCK ON  REP AN
FOSI. THEY'RE 50AL MILES A, THEN
TWO RUSANG WITHIN JUST FIVEHEAM
PORTUGUESESH, DANISH AES. C D F
MECKLEN BOAT
TO THE PTU
BARTOLEUY' MEMBERS
LIPECIAL
FORCES DRILL FOATSGUNSON, WATCWE
TRAINING AND READYING FOR THECLE
T.  TO THE
CABL TO SW EVE
OM M SURFACE MIS
DEPLOYMENT
LOOMS LARGE THIS TASKTWICEMA
SHIPS AND SAILORS I THE
INVASION ASORD ME
NA'S LINE NEW ACTOFAN
AGGRESSION. WE E INYOU, WOLF. YE
FACING NATO ALLIESH ASET THE PRE
MINISTER WHI I THEREAL TERMS THN
SI